what type of story scares you the most
perhaps something dark visceral rooted
in physical danger or something subtle
psychological with layers of unseen
dread or maybe something unknowable
inexplicable that lifts the veil on
reality and exposes the cosmic Terrors
of the universe the work of Japanese
horror manga artist Juni Ido exists at
the inner section of all our greatest
fears his tales capture Primal anxieties
so expertly they can seem truly
mysterious so what I want to do today is
peel back those layers of mystery and
explore what makes junji eo's World
building so darn spooky and to do that
we'll need to find our courage and dive
head first into this ocean of
Terrors our first specimen from the inky
depths of junji eo's imagination is a
fish with strange spider-like legs the
creature comes from the story guo a
narrative famous for being both deeply
Innovative and utterly unhinged the tale
begins with a young man named Tadashi
enjoying a vacation in okanawa Japan
returning from a scuba trip he discovers
at his house a strange fish possessing
what appear to be metallic legs there is
no indication of where such a baffling
life form could have come from with
Tadashi wondering if it's an
Undiscovered species but this creature
is just the beginning on the beach later
that night more fish Scuttle out of the
water on Long spindly limbs a visual
that is equal parts absurd and
unsettling these fish however are merely
Scouts the first wave of an
incomprehensible Invasion across okanawa
sightings of limed marine life become
more frequent on a a fishing tler a day
Hall turns deadly and attacks the crew
the entire ocean seems changed into an
ecosystem of ravenous Terrors with no
species left unaffected from there The
Narrative escalates at a Breakneck Pace
with an army of fish sweeping over the
land like a great wave species from
higher and higher up the oceanic food
chain venture out of the depths a trend
that eventually results in a massive
shark rampaging across the surface
beyond the obvious horror of a land
shark trying to eat you there's an
uncomfortable sense of shattered
boundaries in this scene a feeling that
you're seeing something that simply
should not be Terrors from the sea are a
familiar Trope coming with set
expectations as to when the monster can
strike and when characters are safe but
guo destroys that barrier of safety
eliminating all places to hide from the
creatures of the Abyss the violent
Collision of Realms creates a tangible
helplessness a certainty of Extinction
Central to Juni eo's style of
horror there's another story about dark
things emerging from the depths one that
can help us better understand The
Madness of Juni eo's goo The Surreal
video game death stranding is set in the
wake of a cataclysm where entities known
as Beach things entered our world and
though the creatures emerged not from
the sea but from a Purgatory like Realm
called the beach the parallels between
the apocalypses of death stranding and
guo are Illuminating both are stories of
Worlds colliding of incompatible
environments smashing together with
catastrophic consequences the Clashing
of Worlds can be felt in designs that
merge the mechanical with the biological
the incongruent elements forced together
in a way that seems almost painful
there's a sense that the marine life in
guo in the beach things and death
stranding didn't ask to be dragged
ashore and are just as much victims of
this Collision as
Humanity one lesser known short story of
junji idos titled the thing that drifted
ashore Dives deeper into the horror and
tragedy of a life form stranded out of
its element and is the missing puzzle
piece in understanding how Ido and death
stranding fit together the narrative
begins with the corpse of a massive
creature washing up on the shores of the
Pacific Ocean it resembles a mighty
serpent although decompression from
rising from the abyss has turned it into
something grotesque its body is bloated
and rotting with a head covered in
tumors and parasites a crowd has come to
watch this shipwreck creature decomposed
among them a boy with a strange
connection to the Sea who serves as the
narrator for much of his life the boy
has been tormented with dreams of the
deep ocean cursed with distressing
visions of great fish that swim through
the Hostile dark the dream started
following a traumatic trip to an
aquarium where the boy witnessed deep
sea fish his mind wasn't ready to
perceive in this regard the boy and the
beach creature have a peculiar
connection with both suffering from
their exposure to the others environment
the theme of environmental suffering in
the thing that drifted ashore is
reminiscent of a real tragic phenomenon
throughout history whales and other
marine mammals have been obs oberved
beaching themselves then collapsing
under their own weight the phenomenon
seems to have worsened due to the
invention of sonar and is known as
satation stranding which notably is
where death stranding gets its title
from on a surface level the beach things
and death stranding parallel the
marooned creatures of Juni Ido and
Earth's real Shores yet the human
survivors inhabiting the
post-apocalyptic world of the game are
also marooned in their own way in the
wake of the catac kisic Clash of
realities Earth has been transformed
into an inhospitable land reminiscent of
the sea floor like marine life on dry
land humans suffer in this new
environment their bodies not built for
such an
ecosystem in the latter half of the
thing that drifted ashore the onlookers
noticed something inside the creature's
stomach through a layer of transparent
skin human beings stare back at the
crowd the survivors of a boat accident
from 7 years prior they somehow became
zombie-like parasites living in the
intestines of the Leviathan after being
swallowed like the boy traumatized by
the aquarium the years of staring into
the abyss through the creatures
transparent skin caused them to lose
their
minds there are some things humans are
not meant to witness things our mind
cannot fathom that defy all
reason the crowd and the thing that
drifted ashore attempt to rationalize
the unknown creature theorizing how it
might have moved through the depths yet
are ultimately unable to understand it
likewise multiple explanations for the
limed fish are put forward in guo from a
military experiment gone wrong to a
natural phenomenon but none seems quite
right a central element of what makes
Juni eo's horror World building so
effective is how much he withholds from
the reader without a clear sense of how
a threat functions your rational mind go
go blank letting you experience Terrors
on a primal level in some respects the
creator of death stranding hideo kajima
takes the opposite approach as his game
has hours upon hours dedicated to
explaining how its Universe Works in
side note Juni Ido himself actually
makes a cameo in one of these expository
sequences making his influence on the
game more evident but Juni eo's own
horror rarely grants the comfort of an
explanation like staring into the depths
of the sea reading his work can feel
like gazing at something truly
unfathomable and perhaps no story wields
The Terror of the inexplicable better
than the Enigma of amigara fault the
setup is deceptively simple an
earthquake reveals a several kilometer
long fault and upon the rock face for
boing holes shaped like the Silhouettes
of humans become visible people from
Across the Nation are drawn to the
unfathomed able site after seeing it on
the news each of the thousands of holes
appears to extend endlessly into the
dark of the mountain there's no
indication as to where they came from
they simply are and then things get
stranger people in the crowd start to
realize that certain holes are shaped
exactly like them and one by one they
are overcome with a compulsion to enter
their holes disappearing into the
suffocating depths there's an unbearable
sense of claustrophobia this story can
instill making it impossible not to
imagine what it would be like to be
stuck within the holes yourself unable
to move Beyond this physical Terror
There's real psychological dread in the
way people can't escape the impulse to
trap themselves their agency slipping
away as the inexplicable need becomes
all consuming it's really Grim stuff and
maybe kind of funny for as disturbing as
the situation can be there's an
absurdity to the concept that can at
times feel almost comedic this humor is
present in a lot of the margins of junji
eo's work and can at first be difficult
to reconcile with the disturbing subject
matter but understanding how absurdity
and fear intertwine is Central to
appreciating why these stories are so
affecting and to do that we have to talk
about
house
directed by Nobu hiku Obayashi house is
a lot a psychedelic blend of horror and
comedy the film involves a group of
friends visiting the Mansion of an old
woman in the remote Countryside this
seemingly standard plot soon derails
into Total Insanity as common household
objects attack the group the effects
designed to look as fake as possible a
piano eats someone another character has
a fight with sentient futon cushions and
loses one person gets teleported inside
of an evil clock it can seem like
nonsense and a lot of it is but like the
works of Juni EO there's a method to the
madness the silliness makes the rare
moments of genuine Terror more visceral
and unexpected because you're never sure
what kind of scene you'll get next it's
hard to relax compared to Edo's horror
this film definitely leans harder into
absurdity to the point where it can
outright break your brain there's a
scene where a pair of disembodied legs
kick a cat painting which destroys the
spirit of a cat because the cat Soul was
in the painting or it was the painting
but then the cat was also part of the
lady who owns the house so she's
destroyed but then it turns out not
really do not ask me what is happening
because I do not know if parts of house
sound like they were written by a child
they were Obayashi used story ideas from
his young daughter as he believed the
irrational thoughts of a child would
help the movie frighten people on a more
intrinsic level yes much of house is
absurd but ultimately all absurdity
means is a lack of reason and if you
can't reason with something you aren't
safe from it at the end of the Enigma of
amigara fault every main character
succumbs to the need to enter the hole
they were made for months later a
research team discovers the fault
extends to the other side of the
mountain but the holes are no longer the
same shape and from the darkness
something horrifically Twisted is
creeping slowly closer and that's the
last Glimpse you get you're left with no
explanations no resolution just the
terrifying bewildering absurdity of it
all if there's a culmination to junji
eo's work an ultimate merger of fear and
absurdity I'd say it's probably a little
story titled Uzumaki I say little story
but Uzumaki is one of the longest Ido
ever read wrote and in my opinion
ultimately the most unsettling The
Narrative is centered on a city plagued
by a mysterious Supernatural curse that
takes the form of spirals yes spirals
every scare in the story links back in
some way or another to the simple
pattern and if that sounds too strange
to be frightening well wait and see the
spirals start small a man becomes
obsessed with the Whirl of a snail shell
staring at it from for hours tiny
whirlpools appear in the city's water
supply but soon people's bodies begin to
horribly contort into the spiral shape
the pattern spreads like a disease with
everything in the city becoming infected
buildings loop back onto each other like
a swirling Labyrinth plants grow in
Endless dizzying Twirls even the sky
itself becomes a horrible spiral the
clouds becoming a dark omen of the
city's fate one of the most disgusted
elements of Uzumaki is how helpless the
main characters are in the face of such
a cosmic incomprehensible threat like
the shape itself there's an
inevitability to the spirals a sense
from the beginning that things will only
get worse and worse the story conveys a
level of powerlessness few pieces of
media have
[Music]
achieved if Uzumaki has a companion
another narrative experience that makes
makes you feel similarly insignificant
in the face of unknowable dangers I'd
argue it's the indie game World of
horror created by polish developer pavl
kosminsky the point-and-click adventure
is all about making the player feel as
defenseless as possible in the story you
solve mysteries in a city afflicted by
enigmatic entities known as the old gods
the plot in Aesthetics are explicitly
inspired by the work of Juni Ido and
playthroughs can really feel like you're
living through one of his stories you're
constantly on the back foot trying to
manage your character's dwindling sanity
and stamina as you experience a
NeverEnding parade of nightmares in a
randomly generated order it's not really
a game that you win so much as a game
that you undergo play for long enough
and some form of dark fate is virtually
inevitable I don't think it's much of a
spoiler to say Uzumaki has a similar
ending as is the case across Juni Ido
stories there's no winning against
something so irrational it's impossible
to understand in the Final Chapter
there's some explanation as to where the
spirals come from but it's so vague it
functions less like an answer and more
like another question another layer in
an infinite
mystery balancing ambiguity and a
irrationality with genuine fear is a
tricky thing Juni Ido pushes these
Concepts near their breaking point in
hellstar Ramina an absolutely Bonkers
narrative about a planet that appears in
her solar system out of the blue what at
first seems like a passing celestial
object turns out to be something else
entirely as the planet opens a single
Giant Eye and beholds the Earth idido's
reoccurring theme of Humanity's
insignificance is perhaps at its most
extreme in these panels with Earth
rendered a meaningless Speck in a cruel
Cosmos all attempts by humans to to
understand the interstellar visitor and
in disaster and mass hysteria grips the
entire population and from there well
let's just say that the Rogue Planet
turns out to have a rather large
appetite it's some truly out there media
to the point where it might be too much
for some people but juni's content is
meant to be out there meant to be so
surreal and at times even ludicrous that
you can't anticipate what happens next
one of junji eo's more lightheart works
is his cat diary an autobiographical
story about getting over his fear of his
wife's cats and while nothing disturbing
happens in the actual plot the art is
still so comically unsettling with the
ordinary cats portrayed like their
Cosmic Terrors to me this is Ido
reminding us that the absurdity of his
horror is a feature not a bug an
essential part of what makes his work so
consistently
unpredictable eo's stories are an
exercise in tonal contradictions which
is likely why his work is so hard to
adapt despite many attempts most
translations of his narratives to other
mediums feel like they're missing
something even something as simple as
adding color to his illustrations can
throw off his delicate balance of
ambiguity that's why one of my favorite
adaptations is probably mold an episode
from a recent Netflix Anthology that
keeps things in black and white the
original short story tells the tale of
someone returning to an old house only
to find a nauseating mold has taken over
the foundations the lack of color is a
huge part of what makes the art so
effective as it's difficult to tell what
the mold really is the episode's choice
to keep the color drained from each
scene preserves that uncertainty that
creeping sense that something else is
going on in the house the visuals works
so well I honestly wonder if all
adaptations of Juni Ido shouldn't stick
to Black and White
Adult Swim has been working on a pen and
in adaptation of Uzumaki for a long long
time and I sincerely hope it's as good
as early footage makes it seem for the
dream of a perfect adaptation that
recaptures everything that makes junji
os's art so special is difficult to let
go
of But ultimately juni's work is
irreplaceable for a reason the artist
has been quoted as saying he'll spend
multiple days refining a single panel
making sure the image perfectly captures
the terror of what he's trying to convey
and you can feel that in every line that
Relentless attention to detail that
makes his art so rewarding to revisit
and analyze yet at the same time his
stories often don't take themselves too
seriously reminding us that absurdity is
just as much a part of life as bodily
Horror in the end like a pair of severed
legs kicking a cat painting juni's art
is a deeply original blend of fear
sillly ambiguity and irrationality as
difficult to summarize as it is to
duplicate as always thanks for watching
if you enjoyed this entry please lend
your support by liking subscribing and
hitting the notification icon to stay up
to date on all things curious see you in
the next
video